(upbeat drum and flute music)
- [Narrator] For centuries,
Koreans have believed
in the medicinal properties
of a folk remedy called jukyeom,
or in English, bamboo salt.
Bamboo salt is ubiquitous in South Korea.
It is made by repeatedly roasting salt
in stalks of bamboo.
Its adherents claim it combats disease,
indigestion and pain.
But what's certain is
it's not easy to make.
The definitive method was fashioned
in the early 20th century
by a famed medicine man named Kim Ilhoon.
Near the end of Kim Ilhoon's life,
his son, Kim Yoonse, established
a bamboo salt company
that preserved and industrialized
the family's salt-making method.
For Kim, the three-year
process is worth every minute.
Producing it is a way to honor
both this uniquely Korean remedy,
and his father's legacy.
(airy, cheerful music)
(electronic tone)